pop quiz time let's test your
intelligence so
what is the capital of france
why paris may we
okay now complete the sequence
a1
b2
c
did you say three
yeah that's pretty easy but that wasn't
the real quiz here's what i really want
to know
which form of thinking did you use to
solve each question
well recalling previously acquired
information like a capital city is a
form of intelligence
known as crystallized intelligence
whereas the use of reasoning and logic
to deduce the next character in a
sequence
that is known as fluid
intelligence
my name is martin keane and i'm a master
inventor at ibm so crystallized
intelligence refers to knowledge that
comes from previously acquired
information
it's dependent on a person's knowledge
on their skills on their expertise
developed over a lifetime of learning
and experience crystallized intelligence
is fact
and experience based
whereas fluid intelligence is the
capacity to think logically and solve
problems in new and unfamiliar
situations independent of acquired
knowledge
fluid intelligence represents a person's
ability to problem-solve using reasoning
and by also using
logic
when you come across a new problem that
your current knowledge can't address you
call on fluid intelligence to resolve it
now
the notion of fluid and crystallized
intelligence dates back to 1963
when it was first formalized by
psychologist raymond cattell
now you might be asking yourself
why am i
talking about psychology in an ibm
technology video well
because these two forms of intelligence
that we use to solve problems every day
can also play an important role in
machine learning so for example consider
an ai system like ibm watson to answer a
question it can sift through like a
million books per second and perhaps the
answer to a question is right there in
one of those books like our paris
example
in that case it's a simple case of
natural language understanding to answer
the question what is the capital of
france that's crystallized intelligence
but most problems aren't that simple and
to solve them we may need to combine
both crystallized and fluid intelligence
together
so for example say we wanted an a i
travel system
let's build one
an ai travel system and what we want it
to do
is to build us an itinerary of the best
way to spend a day in paris so the
output of this
is an itinerary
we need to use our knowledge of parisian
geography and cultural history to build
a corpus of what's available
that's the crystallized intelligence
part but we also need to apply those
options to a derived understanding of
the types of activities that we like to
do
so these are the sorts of things that
we'd be interested in doing what do we
normally do when we visit a new city are
there comparable options here in paris
can we tailor this to our personality to
our budget and our willingness to try
new things all of that stuff well that's
the fluid intelligence side of things
so from there a system could derive a
subset of all the possible things to do
in paris that day distilled into a
tailorized personalized
itinerary
so for us humans our crystallized
intelligence is knowledge we acquire and
fluid intelligence is how we apply it
for an ai system you can think of a
systems model as being crystallized
intelligence because it teaches itself
to do one task really well by training
on massive data sets of prior experience
then you can think of its ability to
solve new problems as being fluid
intelligence because it can
apply that model to a previously unseen
problem
and as for me
my crystallized and fluid intelligence
is telling me that
morning croissants under the eiffel
tower
should be top of my list
if you have any questions please drop us
a line below and if you want to see more
videos like this in the future please
like and subscribe
thanks for watching